the third and final presidential debate
last night Donald Trump Hillary Clinton
did Trump mess up how badly did he mess
up or did he dominate that's what we're
going to figure out today we are getting
very very close to this presidential
election and I know there are many
people in the audience who are feeling
very fatigued by this election and they
will be glad for it to be over I will
also be glad for it to be over but I
will be more glad if Donald Trump is not
the president-elect of the United States
on November 9 so this debate was tense
from the beginning the first debate had
podiums and an opening handshake the
second debate had no podiums and no
handshake and at the beginning of this
debate they just walked to their podiums
and did not even look at each other you
could really sense the tension from the
beginning of this debate I had some
thoughts as to how Hillary Clinton
should go about addressing some of the
major media stories that had built up
over the last week or ten days there was
this question of how would Hillary
Clinton addressed accusations of sexual
assault by women against Donald Trump I
said that she really shouldn't dig into
the specifics she'd have nothing to gain
and she should just say she wants to
focus on the issues she didn't bring it
up but she did answer Chris Wallace's
questions about it we're going to get to
that a little bit later there was this
issue of the rigged election which I
thought was an area of opportunity for
Hillary Clinton to really slam Trump for
the fundamentally anti-democratic things
that he's saying basically by saying
that the election is rigged he is he is
sort of saying that he doesn't believe
in our democracy in some fundamental way
I think she did well there we're going
to talk about that and then we have also
issues of how did chris wallace as the
Fox News host impact the dynamic of the
madhuri of the debate by being the
moderator now my sense was that chris
wallace was going to press both
candidates and he sort of did in
different ways it's sort of debatable
whether chris wallace impacted the
debate in a way that was helpful to one
candidate over the other although i
think generally the topics
to favor Donald Trump here's one example
I want to start with this is a question
about the Supreme Court and it's really
a question that is a sort of softball
for the conservative minded candidate
what's your view on how the Constitution
should be interpreted really getting
into this red meat that the
constitutional fetishists who often tend
to be on the right love let's take a
look at Hillary Clinton's answer on this
question first of all where do you want
to see the court take the country and
secondly what's your view on how the
Constitution should be interpreted is do
the founders words mean what they say or
is it a living document to be a flaw
applied flexibly according to changing
circumstances in this segment Secretary
Clinton you go first you have two
minutes thank you very much Chris and
thanks to UNLV for hosting us you know I
think when we talk about the Supreme
Court it really raises the central issue
in this election namely what kind of
country are we going to be what kind of
opportunities will we provide for our
citizens what kind of rights will
Americans have and I feel strongly that
the Supreme Court needs to stand on the
side of the American people not on the
side of the powerful corporations and
the wealthy for me that means that we
need a Supreme Court that will stand up
on behalf of women's rights on behalf of
the rights of the LGBT community this is
a good answer from Hillary Clinton
because it's a question that as I said
is a question that favors so-called
small government conservatives the
problem I have with it as reasonable as
Hillary Clinton is is that she touts a
super progressive position on the
Supreme Court where the big thing is
standing up for the little guy instead
of the big corporation it's sort of
ironic given Hillary Clinton's
relationship with corporate America so
she she gave an answer that turned a
conservative friendly question into
something that sounded progressive but
we know because we've been following
this election and Hillary
for some time that it's a little bit
counter to Hillary Clinton's actual cozy
relationship with Wall Street and big
corporations now Donald Trump tweeted at
3:00 a.m. that he won the debate and as
we often say as Newt Gingrich has even
said if you're tweeting at 3:00 a.m. and
you're a presidential can that it's
something has not gone quite right a CNN
poll says that Hillary Clinton won what
really matters is how this will affect
the polls and we'll see that in a few
days
Hillary Clinton starting at least optics
wise with a strong answer to a question
that Chris Wallace arguably gave the
easier side to or set up for more
success Donald Trump let's get into some
of the other areas of the debate there's
so much that went on in this debate that
I want to talk to you about